it's so important to fight for what you
believe in you have to pedal even harder
I'm just stubborn enough to keep walking
forward it's never been about even
making a living you know I started a
band and the world laughed at me you're
the ones who inherit the earth I don't
think I've ever heard the applause I
think in order to be an artist you have
to be committed beyond reasonable doubt
that doesn't always happen and it's not
a great way to make a good friend yeah
well you should have requested it on the
radio more buddy he's an American actor
singer songwriter and director he's the
lead vocalist and main songwriter for
thirty Seconds to Mars he's a method
actor known for his constant devotion to
and research of his roles
he's Jared Leto and here are his top ten
rules for success it's so important to
fight for what you believe in if there's
ever something that you wanted to stand
up for you know I mean look at us and
follow our lead it is absolutely
necessary to fight for what you believe
in big or small I think some people and
maybe I used to think once you got
successful you could you're successful
in it okay you know you can kind of just
relax a little bit and but that's not
the case at all you have to pedal even
harder you have to work even more there
are more opportunities that need more
time and dedication and in order to do
them well you have to really really
hunker down and do the hard work but
I've never been afraid of hard work and
I always tell people when I'm asked and
it's pretty often that I'm asked about
dreams and achieving creative goals that
I always believe that the bridge between
reality and a dream is work and I always
in moments of despair and doubt and dark
days a focus on on the work I show up
and I work and I work and I work and I
work someone asked if all of your dreams
have been fulfilled no certainly not but
many have I've I think that the really
interesting thing about
achieving some of your goals in life is
you realize that dreams are possible and
they're they're attainable and once you
reach some of these goals you're more
likely to try to reach others and I
always tell people who ask me about
things like this that you know that you
have a good chance at making some your
wildest dreams come true most people
don't even try sadly most people try and
then stop or give up
very few people try and try and try or
do and do and do and do and never give
up and those are the people that that
ultimately succeed and when and it's I
never think that I really have anything
special to offer I'm just stubborn
enough to keep walking forward and put
one foot in front of the other even even
when I have a lot of doubt I just keep
marching for it and working hard not to
sound too much like Anthony Robbins
hearing up a little but you can do it
thank you
if you know the whole acting musician
tech thing doesn't work out you have
good motivational speakers whether you
go deep Deepak Chopra watch out buddy
that's coming for you exactly right I
mean what does it mean to survive as a
mission as a musician what does it take
you know we we make money we make a
living um and it's a great living now
after you know we were signed in 1998 so
we invested in ourselves time energy
passion blood sweat tears as well as
other things and you know it took a long
time and now we have an incredible
touring life so the touring is really
where most artists pay the rent you know
there's there's an accepted wisdom that
artists really don't think so much about
making a living from selling albums but
for me it's never been about even making
a living it's been about passion it's
about about making something from
nothing it's been about sharing things
with other people
well it's been about creativity and it's
been about dreams and that's what it
should always be about I think I have an
insatiable appetite to make things and
share things with the world I have you
know I'm compelled beyond a reasonable
doubt to do what I do I don't think that
it can be a reasonable or logical choice
I think at a certain point you're
compelled to do it it's too painful too
brutal too neurotic of a path to take
otherwise sorry look Mike is making
noise so I think that that compulsion
has to be there it has to be something
that you you can doubt all the time but
deep down inside you know that this is
something you have to do and you know I
think I've dealt with some of the
adversity some of the challenges of
which we've had many you know I started
a band and the world laughed at me
literally laughed at me kicked us around
talked [ __ ] about us in the press for
years and still do you know but we
hunkered down we worked and we worked
and we worked we play arenas all over
the world we have the most amazing
brilliant beautiful fans one could ever
ask for and we've had an incredible life
as a result so if I had listened to the
choir to the chorus of everyone I would
have stopped because that's what people
want you to do for some reason some
people would rather kill your dream than
see you succeed I don't know what that
is you know I mean I and RAM talks about
that as the looters you know we can
debate her in that some other time but
you know I think it's important to be
stubborn and to to follow your dreams no
matter what you know as a kid who is
pretty different himself I think that
you know what I would tell people that
are individuals out there is you know
you're the ones who inherit the earth
and believe in yourself and be patient
and be as different as you want to be
you have every right to do that and it
may be difficult and lonely at times but
there
is no greater privilege than owning
yourself it's fun you know being in and
making art in general is about bravery
it's about taking chances it's about
kind of walking down a more
uncomfortable path sometimes and that
that I always challenge myself to do
that even if it's being foolish so what
does I come from I think it comes from a
desire to create things and share them
with people to be of service when I'm on
the stage I really think of it as I am
there to serve you and not myself I
don't think I've ever heard the applause
and you probably know what I mean by
this I'm always thinking how can I do a
better job I think in order to be an
artist you have to be committed beyond
reasonable doubt if you to be a writer
you have to be committed beyond a
reasonable doubt that'll be the subtext
to the subtitle to the the talk today
committed beyond a reasonable doubt and
I think that when you take the road less
traveled you have to have that
commitment and I think that you know
people may go to some shows for a party
I think people come to our shows for
something else entirely when I was a kid
on more than one occasion I got in the
fight with somebody in the schoolyard
and the next day they were you know
close friends so that doesn't always
happen and it's not a great way to make
a good friend but there are
opportunities for people to take some of
their mistakes
and make them right and there's nothing
more powerful than somebody who has made
a mistake to promptly admit it and to
make amends that can be an incredible
thing and I think a lot of people have
probably done that I've had regret and
have changed and have learned that what
they've done is hurt other people and
come back and said you know what hey I
messed up I'm sorry and uh you know I
I'd like to make it right so you know
for people that have done that out there
that have picked out other people and
bullied it's never too late just to to
stop and and be like hey I'm tired of
being the the [ __ ] here today I'm
going to start being someone else you
have bad days and you know from the
outside people may look at my life and
think that everybody's everything's good
all the time and it's really just not
the case you can have dark days it
doesn't matter how well your career is
doing you know there's all kinds of
things happen in life but as far as
creative dreams go you know I remember
we had released the first song off our
second album and it bombed it did
terribly was called attack and yeah well
you should have requested it on the
radio more buddy because nobody else
thought so and you know maybe there were
other forces working at that time
against us but I thought it was a decent
song as well for the time uh but it
bombed the record company wanted to drop
us they actually did they called our
management's that we're dropping the
band
somehow you know they convinced the the
head of the record when Jason Flom the
guy was in there to come to see us one
more time at Madison Square Garden we're
opening for Audioslave and the crowd
hated us right they hated us it was just
but it was a beloved crowd was largely
there is made up of Soundgarden and Rage
fans a lot of older people and they just
were like who are these weirdos on stage
will they get out of here
but anyway we played that show in the
president of the record company who had
wanted to drop us he decided to give us
one more shot but that time was really
brutal you know it's our second album we
knew if we got dropped it would be very
difficult to ever find a way to make
music and share it again this was way
before uh you know iTunes it was way
before Facebook and it was way before
YouTube as a way before it was so easy
to make and distribute music and share
your work online
you know so it was a challenging time
and really dark but I decided to direct
the video myself it was for a song
called the kill they released it and it
changed our lives so you know and that's
that story has kind of happened more
than a few times in our careers you know
and it's happened to me as an actor it's
happened to me as a director I've looked
at things so many times videos that you
guys see now and think oh that's pretty
good and just wanted to like rip my
eyeballs out it was so bad so I think
the thing that we don't teach each other
and remind each other enough of is that
failure is oftentimes more important
than success and success is the thing
that can actually make us fail it's
really important to note what the
lessons are to learn in failure and it
happens a lot it doesn't feel good but
it's a necessity thank you so much for
watching I made this video because
Sebastian asked me to so there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of Jared
Leto's top 10 rules meant the most to
you leave it in the comments and I'll
join in the discussion thank you so much
for watching continue to believe and
I'll see you soon
now I hope to never look back I don't I
don't really care so much about that
sort of thing legacy or what do I want
to leave behind I don't really think
about it's good to be here now and to
live dreams now to share the dreams with
with all of you I was reading you go
method with the parts uh-huh
how does that occur because in my mind
like fene I've done very little acting
we've nailed it what we've done
but what episodes of home in a way so
yeah what you're talking about yeah to
be honest I passed my city on to my
auntie's that's cool
but um but is like look you going method
cool and you're in the scene and that's
fantastic and then they break and they
gotta go for lunch and you've gotta stay
in that character and order you know
your chicken wings and a bit of salad as
that person is anyone looking at you
gotta know what he's doing just a lot I
think the first thing to note is I I
wasn't ordering any food because I had
lost 30 or 40 pounds
so yeah the meals were out of the
question but just alcohols water Thanks
yes if that and you know it's not a very
social time but really how did you put
it go and method is that wheezing cuz
that's what all this method is again I'm
not a good actress I don't know the turn
it's an interesting way but it's going
method is an interesting way to put it
because you kind of do go there but it's
really just a way to stay incredibly
focused and committed and concentrated
it's a way to kind of shut everything
else out and to prioritize what's
important that's really another way to
describe going method you don't have to
sit around and really believe that
you're this other person yeah but but it
does help to kind of put a wall up
around and to raise the importance of
the process and I found that in my
career that's been the best way for me
to work yeah and obviously it something
worked about the part and the role in
the process because you know at the end
of the day what's important is does the
does the am I able to contribute to the
story to people believe in the character
does the character touch people and
you know I would hope it would the
answers would be yes when I was a kid I
oh I would often stand up to people and
I think that people had a sense they
knew that even though I was skinny and
small uh and I certainly wasn't the
toughest kid on the block that I wasn't
going to let you get away with it so
there's something to that to standing up
for yourself and saying you know what no
uh-uh
because a lot of times you know the dogs
bark is worse than the bite so I found
that to be true a lot of times but it's
difficult to encourage some young person
to confront someone else because that
can lead to escalation but I think it's
okay to stand up for yourself I think
it's okay to look somebody the eye and
and tell them to stop and to demand some
respect